Hey, guys, I'm starting to think maybe the
Supreme Court was a good enough reason to
vote for Hillary Clinton.
After all, they've done it.
Donald Trump, Supreme Court nominee to replace
Ruth Bader Ginsburg, has been confirmed by
the Senate and sworn in at a very trashy event
last night at the White House.
Amy CONI Barrett is in and it is over.
Republicans during Barack Obama's presidency
saying we don't confirm Supreme Court justices
in the last year of a presidency.
And with seven last night, just shy of a week
or just beyond one week to go before a presidential
election, confirming and swearing in a Supreme
Court justice.
And Amy CONI Barrett will now be on the court
to rule over any possible election related
matters.
And there very well may be some which we will
be talking about this week.
So not coming as an acute surprise in the
sense that we determine weeks ago there was
no way for Democrats to prevent this from
happening, and indeed they did not prevent
this from happening.
And she is now on the court.
They won.
Gotta hand it to him.
Mitch McConnell gleeful on Fox News last night.
And this is how it works.
Sadly, they stopped Barack Obama's nominee,
Merrick Garland, because they controlled the
Senate.
They stopped it with garbage arguments, which
they immediately threw into the trash.
And now under Donald Trump, because they control
the Senate, Trump has confirmed three Supreme
Court justices and we have a six to three
majority against the better judgment of doctors
everywhere.
The Trump administration put together a White
House event to swear in Amy CONI Barrett last
night, Melania Trump, who still had Corona
virus symptoms serious enough for her to miss,
attending a Trump rally just days ago, showing
up with no mask at this event right near a
whole bunch of people.
Here is Trump making no sense whatsoever.
And they came completely nonsensical, run
on sentence.
They're fulfilling the duty that passes to
each new generation to sustain the national
traditions and virtues that make possible
everything we have achieved before that we
will do tomorrow because of just unintelligible
and then eventually the swearing in itself
taking place with Clarence Thomas happening
naturally without masks or social distancing.
Clarence Thomas at one point whispering into
the ear of Amy CONI Barrett in close proximity
as Donald Trump looks on.
Here is Mitch McConnell, the Republican Senate
majority leader, straight up saying Amy CONI
Barrett will be a political asset way.
But but.
But, but.
But I thought that these justices simply interpreted
the law and applied it to.
No, no, no.
She's going to be a political asset, says
Mitch McConnell.
Voting for Biden?
Well, if you recall, we had a Supreme Court
fight much before the election.
And in twenty eighteen, we actually gained
sage.
I think this nominee will be a political asset
for our candidates around the country.
Not a liability, but an asset.
That's a Supreme Court justice.
He's talking about as a political asset, not
an interpreter of the law, not a mere conduit
through which the Constitution and case law
flow and spit out like a machine, some kind
of decision.
No, no, they're not even hiding it.
A political asset.
And then here is Lindsey Graham, who is in
a very tough race in South Carolina, saying
Amy CONI Barrett will help us to keep our
seats.
We're in a fight for our life.
Help me help all of us keep our seats so we
can do this for more years.
Lindsey Graham, Scott, Lindsey Graham, Republican
senator from South Carolina, in a really tough
situation all of a sudden against the Democratic
challenger, Jamie Harrison says Amy CONI Barrett
might help him to keep his seat.
They aren't even pretending.
Now, we have to really understand a lot of
different things here.
There were leftists who missed the boat in
2016.
Okay.
They said it's not whoever trump Hillary.
It's all the same Supreme Court.
Who cares?
It's not important.
Well, we know we learned that that was the
wrong approach.
We now have three lunatics on the Supreme
Court.
And you could say Hillary Clinton wouldn't
have put a real progressive on the court up,
but she wasn't going to put on religious.
Not ideologues and cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs
jurists.
She wouldn't have done it.
OK.
We would be in.
We wouldn't be talking about is abortion in
danger?
Is gay marriage in danger?
Is religious liberty as it is actually supposed
to exist in danger?
Because remember, their their view of religious
liberty is the freedom of religion to impose
my religion on others.
That's not freedom of religion.
It is now all in danger.
It wouldn't be had Hillary Clinton won.
Well, we now have the 2020 election.
The 2020 election, unfortunately, is now going
to be subject to this court, thanks to Donald
Trump putting three people on it.
So we have a six to three majority for the
right.
We all have to understand.
I mean, listen, I at no point am I going to
gaslight you.
Just replacing Trump with Biden doesn't fix
the court.
It's too late.
OK, we blew it.
We blew it.
This is the court until another justice leave.
So now we need to remove Trump and vote Biden
merely to have a chance to move the court
from six three to five four.
And then if we get it to five, four, to reverse
it to a five four left majority or maybe expand
the court.
Now, we'll be talking more about court expansion.
I will tell you, I am more in favor today
of expanding the court than I have ever been.
There are still political risks.
We're going to talk about it.
I don't think Joe Biden is going to do it
unless he really, really is pushed.
So this is a loss for us.
They want it.
We have to deal with it as it is, not as we
would like it to be.
We have seven days until we can replace Trump
with Biden.
That will prevent Trump from putting anyone
else on the court for four years.
So that is a win, although it doesn't resolve
the situation.
And then lastly, the cherry on top.
Mitch McConnell has adjourned the Senate until
November 9th, putting in a Supreme Court justice
in direct contravention to the principles
he said apply during the last year of a presidential
term in 2016 and then immediately adjourning
the Senate, meaning no corona virus stimulus
even possible before the election.
They won't even reconvene until November 9th.
Unbelievable.
This is the guy.
This is the guy that's running the Senate.
We've got
to end it, guys.
It must be stopped.